la gestation pour autrui la gpa une
pratique toujours en débat en france ici
elle est strictement interdite
contrairement à d'autres pays européens
comme le danemark ou la grèce pourtant à
une époque porter l'enfant d'un autre et
des possibles en france aujourd'hui nous
voulons traiter un thème plus précis
celui des mères porteuses dans cette
émission exceptionnelle par sa gravité
nous avons la chance d'avoir avec nous
la première véritable mère porteuse en
france il s'agit de patricia patricia
première mère porteuse en france en 1984
faisait la une d'un magazine l'émission
aujourd'hui la vie lui donnait la parole
elle y expliquait son geste
[Musique]
à l'époque la gestation pour autrui
n'était pas explicitement interdite en
france ce flou juridique a permis aux
médecins sachent âge et leur
d'accompagner plusieurs dizaines de gpa
et cela malgré l'avis défavorable du
comité d'éthique tout juste créée par
françois mitterrand l'enfant d'une
mère-porteuse c'est l'enfant qui de
celle qui l'a portée de celle qui le
reçoit ou plutôt comme nous pensons tous
un petit peu des deux je pense que les
surtout qu'il est surtout les enfants de
celle qu'ils reçoivent seul qui va
l'aimer dès 1985 des associations de
mère porteuse voit le jour et les
démarches sont rodés la mère porteuse
accouchent sous x
le père inséminateur reconnaît l'enfant
il ne reste plus qu'à sa femme de faire
une démarche d'adoption je trouve que
c'est indispensable que les femmes qui
acceptent de faire ce geste pour rendre
des couples terriblement
ce n'est pas du tout l'attirance de
d'argent
vraiment pas mais la pratique faisait
débat et posaient des questions éthiques
en 1986 le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins condamné à son tour la gp11 ans
plus tard la ministre de la santé
faisait interdire les associations de
mère porteuse il est une loi qui
effectivement interdit que le corps fut
loué acheté ou vendu et ça c'est le code
pénal et le code civil interdit des
conventions
sur des objets qui ne sont pas dans le
commerce et heureusement l'enfant ou
incomplets ne représente pas cela en
1991 la justice s'en mêle dorénavant le
recours à une mère porteuse est
formellement interdit en france la gpa
devenant illégal les couples stériles ou
homosexuels se sont dirigés vers
l'étranger cette pratique a alors ouvert
un autre débat celui du lien de
filiation entre un enfant né d'une gpa
et ses parents d'adoption
[Musique]